tom verducci sports illustrated baseball
senior writer of course working for fox
and mlb during the playoffs he was in
arlington texas last night
the dodgers and the braves game five at
nine eastern on fox sports one time
tom kind enough to join us here you saw
kershaw go out
for the sixth inning what did you think
yeah i didn't have a problem with that
he had a low pitch count he had
seemed to have things in order the issue
was when things started to unravel a
little bit right i mean we've been
watching dave roberts in these
postseasons the last few years and
especially
third time around the lineup i mean he's
quick with the trigger it's the way the
dodgers do business so to me
the flash point it wasn't cursed on
freeman because he's handled freeman
pretty well over the career he made he
made a bad pitch to freeman like a
really bad pitch and the dodgers got
burned with their defense by the way if
you notice
that was a ground ball single turned
into a double because they had mookie
wilson shifted over to right center that
tells me cursor was
supposed to get the ball away from
freeman he didn't
got burned the flash point was ozuna
ozuna actually said after the game
after that oconia infield hit when the
throw was made
you know went into the dugout and he
went to second ozuna said he talked to
freeman and he said
you get on base and then i'll get
greater all
he was already assuming that kershaw
would not pitch to him a third time so
that's the flash point didn't have a
problem with him starting the inning
you know we can think that the uh
dodgers bats you know woke up with 11
runs
in that first inning the previous game
but after the third inning
of that game those bats didn't do
anything i think they had basically
three hits so
it's not like they came alive they came
alive for a moment
and then after that you know that
previous game and then last night
the dodger bats have been pretty silent
here it's like
seeger's the one guy mookie betts hasn't
done much here so
uh bellinger hasn't done much there's a
lot of fingers if you're uh you're
pointing for uh fingers of blame here
tom
yeah it's a great point because yeah i
mean we love talking about
the pitching decisions or manager
decisions on pitchers right
but that's a great point they really
have not hit you think about the guys
who have shut them down you know after
that big outburst in in game three it
was
noah a 22 year old right-hander with
very little major league experience and
last night you had this kid bryce wilson
who pitched an
unbelievable game had seven career
starts
22 years old hadn't pitched in a weekend
with two weeks and a half
so it you know they're not seeing cy
young winners shutting them down maybe
it's just they're not familiar with
these guys but
a big load has to go to the dodger
offense because it was number one in
baseball
this year i also wondered about this
when i was
looking at the nba bubble you saw a lot
of young teams do well because
you didn't have to travel to staples and
play in front of a hostile crowd
you're playing in a basically sterile
environment there
these younger players and the braves had
a lot of younger players
they're there in the they're not a
dodger stadium they're there in
arlington
there's no real you know home field
disadvantage here there's no bullying or
none of that
feels like that plays right into the
braves that it's a young team
they may not know better and they're not
intimidated by any of this
i'm with you especially when it comes to
the pictures there's no question about
that actually last night when the game
started of the nine people on the field
for the braves
five of them were 23 and younger and
they're shutting down
you know this juggernaut of a team
because the dodgers in the regular
season were a juggernaut
i'll tell you because i've been in the
bubble i'm down there it feels like a
college or high school atmosphere
because
the families are really close to the
field here in arlington
there's 11 000 people they're scattered
around it's really not that loud they
still have some fake crowd
noise in there but they're all saying
hello to mom and dad or the girlfriend
it really feels like an american legion
tournament so you're right i think it
does help
especially these young pitchers i mean
you put them in dodger stadium 50
000 people you know triple deck that's a
different atmosphere
than a bubble if uh this doesn't work
out for the dodgers
what happens with dave roberts if
anything
i don't think anything happens really
okay um
you know again it depends how it ends
the next couple of days
if it does i still i'm not counting them
out then i mean this is a really really
good team you saw the way they broke out
in the first inning the other night i'm
not saying they're going to score 11
again
um but man that the lineup is due to
break out with something here at some
point beyond what they did in that one
inning so
i'm not ruling them now it's gonna be
difficult don't get me wrong bullpen day
for the braves today and then you've got
frieden anderson
and i think both those two guys are
legit no matter sweet is probably the
tougher matchup for the dodgers but both
those guys are really good
that curveball is i you know i hadn't
seen much of him but i
i when i watched him i was like oh my
gosh
you know i'm glad you mentioned that
because the way they've shut down the
dodgers here overall
you know the one exception this is not a
high velocity team
we love talking about fastballs and the
dodgers have a million guys coming out
of the bullpen throwing literally a
hundred miles an hour
if you lined up the 16 playoff teams the
braves are
13th in average velocity so you've got
freed with that curveball he's added the
slider you've got anderson with that
killer
changeup i thought wilson did a great
job mixing up his pitches
they're not beating the dodgers with
velocity or pure stuff they're pitching
this group and
you have to give them credit for being
so young and this good
what advice would you give the astros
when it comes to questions about 2017
uh i go full on nuke lelouch and be as
dull and boring as possible
right don't take the bait because you
know what happened in that first
first round with minnesota right carlos
correa they got through minnesota he's
like oh we're back you know we're like
the bills you want to get rid of us you
can't get rid of us
i think some guys talk to him because
the next round they were like
very chill about it i think that's the
way i would hand it don't give anybody
any more
ammunition you've done plenty of that
already and altuve's had a couple of big
hits
are his throwing woes that that was only
one game there
uh no but i can tell you a story here
before that series
the raised scouts in their hitters
meeting before the series
they said when you hit a ground ball to
second base even a routine one
bust it down the line we're not sure if
this guy's gonna make the play
so they saw something there with his
body language how deliberate he was the
arm whatever it was
they put those guys on notice so if you
notice choi
and lao busted it down the line on
routine balls and put pressure on him
i'm not sure that goes away that quickly
dan
and you've been around long enough that
we had chuck knoblock and we have steve
sacks mackie sasser couldn't throw the
ball back to the mound
did you ever do i'm sure you did but um
like talk to a psychologist or
somebody who would look at this and say
what happens in the brain
when you know rick ang kills another one
yeah it's when
athletes start to think right they start
to think about the process the lack of
thought you hear that from hitters all
the time right i wasn't thinking
anything just see the ball hit it you
know it's funny the guy pitching when he
pitched in relief last night for the
braves tyler matsuk
he had the yips as a pitcher right he
was out of baseball former number one
pick out of baseball
it took him a year going to see
psychologists
uh psychiatrists uh throwing every day
on his own
and it took him another year in the
minor leagues independent ball to get
back
i think more guys just don't get back
it's really hard to get back from it and
it seems to affect
second baseman as you mentioned there
and the occasional pitcher
but it's an odd throw from second base
it's like an odd throw when a comebacker
goes to the mound the pitcher
is he's guiding it shortstop in third
you have to
unleash it you know it's rare when you
get you know a looper that you can throw
in there second was always
odd and and i was a former shortstop so
you get it you fire second sometimes you
fire sometimes you lob it and it feels
like
sometimes you're right in between well i
think you're on something there when you
have a little bit of
extra time that clock tells you have a
little bit of time that's when the brain
starts to get in the way
of the muscles right if you're a
shortstop in the whole third base
long throw you don't have time to think
about it second baseman knows he has
time and i think that's
that works against them if i would have
told you when uh
the marlins had their outbreak that they
were going to make the playoffs what
would you have said
no way i mean really i mean don
mattingly did an
incredible job with that team i mean you
think about they had 18 people out
uh i think it was 174 roster moves they
went through they had 20 guys make their
major league debuts
in a 60 game season i mean it was crazy
but you know listen that young group
found itself
mattingly did a great job their young
pitching is legit i didn't think it
would come this quickly but
again dad you made the point about
nobody in the stands i think that helped
them
it was sort of a bonding experience too
to go through what they did
but bottom line was i think mattingly
has to be the manager of the year for
the job that he did with that group
uh have fun tonight there nine eastern
on uh fox sports one
and uh it'll be braves and dodgers again
do you think we're gonna live to see
another game i do
i i can't count out the dodgers uh you
know what i think it's a low scoring
game tonight again though because that
braves bullpen
it's a bullpen game brian snickers got a
lot of good options
so you know most cases most teams are up
against it with the bullpen game not the
braves
thank you tom i know you're busy we
appreciate you making some time for
us yeah dan have a good one that's tom
verducci sports illustrated
senior writer working for fox sports and
mlb